- So...uh....let's begin,
at the beginning,
with the probability,
both philosophically and mathematically.
What does it mean to say the probability
of something happening is 50 percent?
What is probability?
- It's a degree of uncertainty,
that an agent has about the world.
- [Interviewer] You're still
expressing some knowledge
in that statement.
- [Guest] Of course, if the
probability is 90 percent,
it's absolutely different
kind of knowledge
than if it's 10 percent.
- But it's still not
solid knowledge, it's....
- [Guest] It is solid
knowledge, (mumbles).
If you tell me that 90 percent (mumbles)
smoking will give you
lung cancer in five years,
versus 10 percent, it's a
piece of useful knowledge.
- So, the statistical
view of the universe,
why is it useful?
So we're swimming in complete uncertainty,
most of everything around us.
- Yes, it allows you to
predict things with certain
probability, and computing
those probabilities
are very useful.
That's the whole idea of.......
prediction,
[Guest] and you need prediction
to be able to survive.
If you can't predict the future, then just
crossing the street
would be extremely.....
fearful.